warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children
viewer discretion is advised hey
everyone welcome to another episode of
led live
what does porn do to your brain
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness well
welcome everyone to another episode of
led live we're so thankful that we can
have our friend
chad cruiser on our show today chad is
been in ministry a long time talking
about a lot of different topics and
today he's going to
walk us through this topic of porn and
what that does to you and
we know that a lot of people struggle
with this even the secular world
recognizes that this is a big big
problem
one of the resources that we've come
across in
discovering you know what the effects of
porn are is
uh fight the new drug which they're
they're not even christian and they're
telling you look
this is ruining your brain so we're
gonna get into that
chat you have a ministry right what is
the name of that ministry
well we have a we have a youtube channel
called health and homestead where we
talk both
about scientific studies on health and
that
includes things like mental health
physical health happiness
in general and also we have
a website called anchor point films
anchor point films we make documentaries
we go around archaeologists
historians theologian scholars medical
professionals we make documentaries on
health
history archaeology the bible
a lot of great documentaries in fact we
have them for sale on our website if you
want to check them out
on littlelightstudio.tv but you can also
check out um
chad's website because these are really
cool documentaries especially if people
are
being introduced to the gospel for the
first time and they have questions like
how do i know what you're saying is real
this is a great place to start
because it really lays the foundation of
can you trust the bible
you know how do we know that what we're
reading
really has historical roots and in fact
um
is true so um definitely check those out
they're
really well done documentaries and i'm
excited about this topic this morning
because
um there is literally probably not a
person on the planet that hasn't
come in contact with this at some point
in time right i mean if we're all
honest at some point in time if you play
with the internet
it is a matter of time before you come
across this and
and i think this is really an important
topic not only for parents to understand
but also um you know anybody that's
that's wanting to
to seek a godly life this is the one
thing that i think the devil gets in
between
like you know like like like when we
were when the children of israel were
ready to cross over into the jordan
right and and
nobody could attack them the way that
they got in the middle of them
and took them out was through the use of
women and whatnot so
this is i think a main tool the devil
tries to get in
and destroy our relationship with him
and so
um this is a much needed topic you know
i'm thinking about just
what you just said so just before they
were going into the promised land
there was this great temptation with
lust and
i was also thinking about what you were
just sharing with me before we started
the show
about a new documentary talking about
childhood 2.0
mikey actually showed me that one did
you guys watch this one
i did we will put a link you can
actually watch it for free on youtube
and
i you know if you own a phone you need
to see this documentary
if you have a child that you think
someday will own a phone
before the age of 30 years old you need
to
actually watch this documentary because
i was blown away at the
access that kids have to nudity to
pornography and to their friends not
just like
porn sites no longer are people like
meeting
and like you know wanting to to meet up
to like kiss
it's like they're sharing nude photos of
each other and that just blew me away
as children yes so i told my my kids you
know maybe when you move out of my house
you can have a phone
but but that doesn't even matter because
if they're in any kind of public setting
public school
private school their friend might have a
phone and hey look what i just found
boom
and now it's been right you can't take
that back yeah
so this is this is information i think
that um you need to be aware of
even if you feel like your child is
completely sheltered and
they will have no access to this you
know what their friends may
and so this i think is also another
topic that that
childhood 2.0 watch the link below
you know um one of my favorite verses
of scripture is deuteronomy chapter 6
verse 24 and it says
and the lord commanded us to do all
these statutes that means
god commanded us to do his commandments
and then he tells us exactly why he told
us
he gave us the commandments it says for
our
good always that he might preserve us
alive as it is this day so
god's commandments are all they're not
for his good it's not like he just said
hey i'm going to tell you
to do this and this and this and this
and this and just do it because i said
so
he said everything i ask you to do is
actually for your own benefit
right and so he's not keeping us from
something to keep us from happiness
he's keeping us from things that would
actually ultimately make us
or detract from our happiness that's
actually the devil whispering at us you
know what i mean if you don't
do this or you don't have this you're
gonna miss out on some fun
you know and that's just his angle that
he hits it but but god literally says
listen if you apply these to
us and and and what you're doing and and
you actually do what i'm telling you to
do you're going to live a better life
totally totally a real thing called fomo
have you heard that yeah
fear of missing out just like yeah i
have to i have to be at that party i
have to talk to this person i have to do
this i have to
that word have to because i'm afraid
that i'll miss out
imagine how many people probably think
man i wish i could
go back and know what i know now or i
wish i knew what would happen in the
future
well god knows god sees the beginning
from the end he says hey if you keep
eating cake every day it's going to kill
you
and that's what all these other rules
are too they're not like hey if you keep
having premarital sex
it's bad if you keep doing any of these
things
it's not because it's fun and i want to
keep you from it it's going to destroy
you
so there's something foundational though
that i think people miss
and and it's like the devil knows how to
cut people off before they even get to
this point
and that is you have to believe that god
has your best interest at heart
if you don't believe that you're not
even going to get here
absolutely right so when you get here
when you come to the understanding that
yes
god loves me god wants the best for me
so when we question that that we start
to be on really dangerous ground that's
exactly what happened to eve
you know when she started to believe
that god didn't have her best interest
at heart
then she took a different direction you
know so if
you're there you know you need to come
to the understanding you need to
battle this out with god and and know
that god has your best interest in heart
that he loves you he cares for you and
he wants
you to have eternal life he wants you to
have a relationship with him
so if you're not there yet start there
but if you're there
now i mean yeah and obviously god wants
the best for you
back to your point going like in the
garden of eden
um it was a perfect environment god is
the parent he had everything under
control
he gave them the information that they
needed and it was an outside source that
came in and just ruined everything
so really to your point that yeah their
friends might be going through something
totally different from
what the home that you're trying to
create so be mindful of it all
right great point you know in jeremiah
chapter 29 verse 11 because here's the
thing when you're when you're trapped in
some kind of addiction
whether it's drugs alcohol i remember
drinking myself to sleep at night
before giving my life to jesus i was
addicted to tobacco
i was trapped i literally wanted to quit
but i wasn't able to quit
and and when you're stuck in something
it seems like you have no hope of a
future at that point like you're stuck
in your addiction and jeremiah 29 11
says for i know the plans that i have
for you declares the lord
plans for wholeness and not for evil to
give you a future and a hope
god says that he wants us to have
wholeness
and the devil wants to give us something
that actually does bring some kind of
pleasure
enjoyment but it doesn't actually make
us whole it makes us fragmented it makes
us
broken and but it still feels good for a
moment so it's not like
the things that we're not supposed to do
don't feel good they do feel good
but then they have like a corresponding
depression that comes with them you
actually so you feel good initially
but maybe the next morning you're like
empty i know i would drink myself to
sleep at night
and you feel good that night but you
wake up more empty than you were
before that it's like an emotional
hangover yeah that's good that's a great
way of saying it it's like that donut
in the glass case right it just looks so
good
but the second you eat it you go why did
i eat that
and it makes perfect sense john 10 10
says the devil comes to steal kill and
destroy
well he doesn't come in swinging because
then you have a chance to react and
defend yourself
he comes in maybe you know shakes your
hand asks you how you're doing
and then he attacks you yeah i got these
watches
hey i got a puppy in the car um
john chapter 4 verses 16
through 19 it talks about a
woman who was basically going from man
to man to man
one of the things that when we think
about history we think like
it used to be different well it was like
you didn't have cell phones to like send
naked pictures around
but humans still did the same things
that humans do today like
people would go from relationship to
relationships they would go they would
sleep around this goes back
thousands and thousand years so it
wasn't like the good old days it's just
always been the same
and this jesus meets a woman and in john
14 beginning in verse 6 it says jesus
said to her
go call your husband and come here the
woman answered i have no husband
jesus said to her you said well i have
no husband for you have had five
husbands
and he whom you now have is not your
husband
this you have said truly the woman said
to him sir i perceive that you are a
prophet
so this woman she's gone from man to man
to man the man she's with is not her
husband
so she's in these non-married
today we call it cohabitation that
that's the term
and i want to actually in this in this
time we have together actually look at
the scientific studies on these things
on these popular
experiences of humanity and see so we
know what god says
god says in order to cohabitate you
should be
married right exactly so if you're going
to be with someone you should marry them
and
yes sex within marriage is actually a
beautiful thing but let's look at the
actual research on this so
cohabitation versus marriage people who
marry according to the research are
significantly
more likely to report having
relationship
satisfaction or happiness than those who
cohabitate
so it's interesting that you know
because you might get a different
idea on television or social media that
oh just being with somebody
and just you know moving in together
that that's so fulfilling because
you know you get to be on your own you
get to do your own things and you're
together and
you don't get tied up with all the
strings that connect you in marriage but
the research actually shows that people
who do
get married are actually happier in
their
marriage and i saw a study that that
happiness leads to longer
life those who are married live longer
than those who just cohabitate
and they were saying it was because of
the relationship aspect so
it's just i don't know what it is about
marriage it just takes us to another
level
psychologically and physically and all
of that that betters our life
it's interesting to me that you can take
the exact same action
i mean literally the same action that
that it's not like you're doing anything
new or different that you wouldn't be
doing if you were just cohabi
cohabitating with somebody but the
actual action of
actually just being married is that that
difference between the two
and it's like one can have a terrible
experience and one can have an
absolutely
like blessed time that's such a great
way of saying because and it goes back
to
god says all my commandments are for
your
good always i mean it's just it's not
really that simple he's like list
listen you do this your life will be
happier very very simple and so so then
you think about this you think well okay
so i can maybe you could just sleep
around you don't actually have to
cohabitate you know you just hang out
sleep with each other and then
you know you have a number of different
partners and someday you could settle
down and
and that would that would be good enough
but let's see what the research actually
has to say on that so
number of lifetime partners and
happiness men and women who have only
ever slept with their spouse
statistically have the happiest
marriages
now i want to say this before i go into
it the great thing is god can forgive
just like the woman who jesus was just
talking to we were just mentioning
that this woman her life was totally
changed by meeting jesus
so god can forgive us no matter what we
have done
but if you haven't done this if you
haven't been sleeping around you haven't
been with anybody
actually saving yourself until marriage
will statistically give you a happier
marriage than you can have
anywhere else and it's actually that
statistic i think is correct me if i'm
wrong
the same even if you like don't believe
in god if you actually have no belief in
god whatsoever but
you statistically have only been with
your spouse
your your happiness is still through the
roof right so it's not even like adding
religion so to say that's that's that's
that it's just like
religion just confirms what the science
now is showing us
and that's that's the point is that all
of god's commandments are for our good
it doesn't say they're
for the good of christians or jews only
it just says his commandments are for
humanity's good if we follow these rules
these commit and
we hate the word rules but basically he
has basically
nine or ten things that he says you
shouldn't do when i say nine or ten
there's ten commandments but one of them
is
you know a couple of them are totally
positive so the some of them are things
you shouldn't do
if we don't do those things that's only
like eight or nine really actually
things that you shouldn't do
and then there's like an infinite amount
of things you can do so like
holding it's like you shouldn't jump off
of cliffs right i mean that's kind of
like yeah that's a good idea what are
you saying
but there's all kinds of things you can
do right like you might jump out of a
plane with a parachute
which is probably not always the wisest
idea either but but you get the point so
yes yes so what do you think that is
think what is why do you think that
people are happier
i mean i i have my own viewpoint i think
i think you have nothing to compare to
yeah so it's like you know you're you're
i think that's a good point i i mean
that let's just be honest right
that that is like ignorance is a voice
i just i just mean that you're not
you're not looking outside
of anything it's like you have nothing
no no idea of that so i mean it's like
your
your idea the way i've heard it
explained is also we have this like
platelet in our brain right
we take mental pictures and that mental
picture is what actually turns us on
and so our idea of what turns us on
is that picture that we see but what
happens if you see this woman this woman
this woman this one this woman
you take a bunch of pictures and you
overlay them over each other now they're
fuzzy
so now your idea of what actually
excites you
is now this convoluted like you know
watered-down
version of that and it takes more and
more stimulation to be able to get that
so
that's that's as simple as i can
understand it mentally
i haven't i have a thought to add to
that
the others are the other options
are non-committal if you're married
you're all in yeah right okay but if
you're the
if you're the co-habiting type or is or
if you're sleeping around
you're not all in right this is kind of
like yeah you know you can have a part
of me
but you know i always got them out and
so the investment isn't there
and both parties mentally realize that
whether they verbalize it or not they
realize it
and so even people today i watch a ted
talk on this
even people today with social media they
will keep up
with other people on facebook that
they're interested in
because it's like having a little black
book well if this doesn't work out
because we've even taken marriage to the
point where it's like well you know i
can always get divorced
yeah unless you are completely
all in you know committed then
it's just going to be like another thing
you just walk away you know and and the
other person knows that they know that
you're not invested to them
and i think it's the same with god you
know it's like are we
all in with god or are we
non-committal he's all in with us he's
told us he poured out all of heaven you
know he came
he lived he died he gave us everything
and we're the one that's like you know
maybe i don't know
but he's fully committed i think that
commitment psychologically
plays on people yeah i think i see it
like that you know like marriage is like
the relationship between god as uh
groups
and we are as his bride and when we are
not fully committed with him like for
example we worship other god
we're not fully happy we can't be fully
happy
but when we are committed to him fully
and we can truly be happy
you know a friend of mine used
illustration i don't know if he made it
up or not but it's a really good one
you know how you have like scotch tape
you know you have this little kind of
see-through tape and and
when you stick it to something it's
pretty sticky
but if you like pull it off and stick it
to an again
and you pull it off and stick it again
you pull it off and stick it again you
pull it off and stick it again
it becomes less sticky right and
we can become like that too like we go
and we connect ourself
through sex through a relationship with
this person and it's like that first one
is
can be very like emotional and impactful
and the next one
can be somewhat so but after a while it
can become
less and less impactful and and our
stickiness might start to go away i
actually believe though
if we really come to christ one of the
things that is wise to do
is to take time away from doing that i
don't just mean take time away from
having sex i mean from even
relationships
sometimes like step back a little bit
and like let your relationship with god
grow
and i think he can start to make that
stickiness come back that we can begin
to
whereas if you if you're just going from
person to person person then you give
your life to jesus and you're like then
you see somebody and they're
they're religious and you're like yeah
now i can do it with somebody not just
sex but even just a relationship
sometimes you just kind of bring your
old ways into christianity and your
relationship with god and then and then
that takes you down a bad road too so
sometimes
i think it's good to just take i did
took a step back
and allow like your connection with
christ hopefully to make
you more sticky to the one that he if
each you know calls you to be with
somebody
i like that analogy i was thinking you
know
i guarantee if i was a betting man i
would bet on this but
if you talk to any prostitute i
guarantee none of them got into the
business
as a virgin like i'm going to i'm a
virgin why don't i become a prostitute
i guarantee they've had terrible
relationships many of them
and then they're like this ain't nothing
i can get paid to do this all right
but like you said the first one was
probably a very
you know a close relationship yeah it
was like high school sweetheart you
thought that was going to be the one or
whatever
then over time it just becomes this
thing like whatever i can just do with
anybody
or sadly a bunch of abuse you know
sexual abuse that like
you've done it so much it just becomes
part of life and you make money
and talking to people who have a high
body count
they keep talking about themselves it's
very self-centered i i i'll be able to
handle a marriage or i'll i give my full
attention to the person that i'm with at
the time i i
they're not really thinking about their
partner and when going into marriage and
there's
this boom of conversation of
relationships and how it should be
and marriage is like you know i need to
take care of my emotional baggage i
don't want to put it on the other person
well what about sexual baggage you have
all these different partners and now you
come to this person
and it affects you subconsciously where
what if that person doesn't meet the
standards that you have set now that you
have set for yourself
and it's that kind of baggage going into
it that may cause a lot more damage than
than good on that other person uh
we talked a little bit about
cohabitation we're going to get to
pornography specifically but we're kind
of
doing the broad picture and then we're
going to go specifically into porn but
in john chapter 8 verse 3 and 4 it says
the scribes and pharisees brought a
woman
taking an adultery having set her in the
midst they
they told him they told jesus teacher we
found this woman in adultery in the very
act
and without getting too deep into it the
dude is not there
right so this is like a total setup
right it's not like in the very act of
what like was she alone no she wasn't
alone so
so this is obvious that they set this up
they gotta go guy to go sleep with this
lady and and then they come in burst in
while they're in the act
and they grabbed the woman but not the
guy so they let the guy go which is
these guys were and think about it these
are like pastors they're not pastors
because there were no pastors
but like theologians these are like the
religiously talk about wicked men right
they actually set a dude to go commit
adultery and then they go grab her
bring her to jesus because they wanted
to stone her or they they would like to
but they know if jesus says stone her
then
then he's going to get in trouble with
the roman government because the roman
government doesn't give the jews
the right to execute people capital
punishment which is the main point
anyway so they're willing to risk her
life just to get jesus in trouble
it is such and this also goes to and i'm
not meaning to talk about this
but when religious people
abuse sexually it is a very ugly thing
it is a very ugly thing and i and i feel
for anybody and anybody out there if
you've gone through something
in church or from a religious leader i'm
sorry that you went through that
and that's not jesus
jesus was in pain for you
and is in pain for what you've gone
through so so do not think that that is
what jesus is yes it happens
and it's happened like crazy and you
know certain places
but jesus loves you and he can give you
victory and he can give you
uh what my wife calls emotional amnesia
not that you have amnesia
but he can set you free from that crazy
burden inside of you
and so but talking about this woman
whether it was a one-night stand or
whether she had been with this dude
before i don't know but let's just
we're going to talk now about the
research on like
just casual sex so the media typically
portrays
sex uh free sex you know just open sex
with random people
as something that brings pleasure
instant gratification
and maybe even happiness but what is the
research actually show
when it comes to just like things like
one night stands well the good news is
they've already done the research we
don't have to guess
research in 2013 found that casual sex
was correlated with suicidal and
depressive thoughts and for each
sexual encounter suicidal thoughts
increased by 18
18. this is unbelievable
and so you don't see this on you know
standard television shows and movies
right
so after five you're nearly at 100.
yeah and i don't know if it's like at 18
yes i mean
you can see that it's a very bad number
at that point
isn't that just sad because you know and
just speaking openly
like sexual the best sexual pleasure
is others focused right it's not what
can i get out of this
and the devil has perverted this act
that god has given to us that is
supposed to
bond us together like glue it is like
supposed to be the one thing that you're
just like
you know like so honed in and zeroed in
on
on your mate right yeah and he's now
flipped it into
this such selfish act and i think that's
that's what probably contributes to this
is it's like here it's like it was never
designed for that
and when we use it like that it's just
like the devil has
you know free reign totally totally and
now once again you may have done these
you may have had sex you may have been
with multiple people
and the good news is what the way that
jesus responded to the woman who was
taken in adultery she was just
literally literally it's one thing if
like you've had sex
in the past this woman was seconds
before
actually in the midst of sex right and
what ends up happening
john 8 10 and 11 she's standing before
jesus actually maybe on the ground but
when jesus lifted up himself because he
went and wrote in the dust of the temple
when jesus said lifted him up himself
and saw none but the woman
he said to her woman where are those
nine accusers where are the ones who
accused you
has no man condemned you she said no man
lord
and jesus said unto her neither do i
condemn you
go and sin no more she's standing before
the judge of the universe you can
imagine she feels guilty
she feels ashamed she feels like she
could never be in his presence
but yet she is in his presence and he
says to her
i don't condemn you go and sin no more
so he doesn't say i don't condemn you
but like you're free to go and do your
thing
no he says go and sin no more because he
knows that sin
breaks us it makes us fragmented broken
but remember jeremiah 29 says he wants
us to
to be whole that's what he wants so why
do you think this is so
taboo where is a taboo coming from if
you tell someone every time you take a
drink
you're doing damage to your body that
makes sense to them they understand they
may do it anyway but they understand
when you tell someone that having
several sexual partners
does damage to your body they're like no
i don't believe that or you know it's
not true
why do you think that is it's like
heroin right i mean
how many heroin movies have you watched
where it just ends
bad you know what i mean i just blows my
mind that people still try it
like that is a mind-boggling thing to me
like have you not seen
like enough of these things the way they
play out but yet this is the same kind
of it's like the sex thing you you were
mentioned earlier you don't start off
with like
all of a sudden one day you're 12 and
you're like man i should just try some
heroin right
right you start off with like a
cigarette and then you move on to
alcohol and then marijuana or whatever
it could be different order but
but very few people just like start off
with heroin no no but the question was
you know why is heroin although it's
still used
viewed as a bad thing everyone can agree
that it is but not necessarily having
several sexual partners that was the
question
um the bible tells us that our hearts
are deceitful above all else and
desperately wicked
and i've quoted this for so many times
and i can't think of it
yeah so and then hebrews also tells us
um that we are hardened through the
deceitfulness
of sin right it's it's
probably the greatest deception is
self-deception right
and we're all just prone to this
i guess call it confirmation bias if you
will
oh yeah it doesn't affect me right or
it's gonna affect everybody but me
there was a there was a video i seen not
too long ago as a doctor from byu
and he was looking at a study of you
know violence in video games and he was
quizzing college students
and he was asking them you know does
violence and video games
affect you know these different groups
of people and their
age group their demographic was one of
them
by and large the numbers are like oh
yeah that definitely
affects you know them so you know he has
his sample size
and then he asked them if it affects
that oh yeah no no no no
no he's like wait a minute these numbers
should correlate
and they do not there's a huge disparity
here it's like you're all agreeing that
affects your demographic but then you
all deny that it affects you so how does
that work you know
it doesn't make sense and that's the way
we are somebody can tell us
um you know that's bad for you oh yeah i
get that it's bad but
it doesn't affect me yeah totally that's
just human nature
i'm going to go out on a limb here but
i'm going to call it like the
programming of the world
that basically how many times do people
see a wrong picture of what happens
holds relationships so in every single
movie and every single song
and every single thing they see this
glorified version of
what that looks like and they don't
realize like when you watch that
girly flick with you know the guy who
meets the girl for the very first time
and they
go home that night and they have sex and
there's lights and music and all that
right does it ever happen like that
no generally never and and then the
feeling they never show you the day
after yeah they never show you the
thoughts that those people are having
after that act is done yeah and that
goes back to your earlier statistic
where i guarantee you enough times those
thoughts run through everyone's mind we
are biologically
literally the same right and i think
that's it's exactly what
one of you were saying that oh it was
you bro the the
nobody goes and just you've seen the
movies on heroin and nobody ends at the
end of the heroin movie after doing
heroin over and over like
successful in business and like does
well right
but people do in movies just go have
sex and sex and sex with many different
people and they're still cool
they're still good-looking they're still
successful they're a little more yeah
they're almost like the cooler they
they are the better they do yeah and one
thing i think you know with
with heroin and meth and all this you
see it like people's teeth are falling
out they got scars on their face
most of the time when somebody gets an
std they don't tell anyone yeah it's so
embarrassing that even their best friend
doesn't know
so you know you go to school and you get
the talk like
you can get chlamydia and all these
things and you're like what happened to
me i don't know
anyone with it well guess what the
person next to you probably hasn't
yeah they're just not talking about it
that's right and so
jesus with this woman he says neither do
i condemn you go and sin no more romans
1 8
says there is therefore now no
condemnation to those who are in christ
jesus
who don't walk according to the flesh
but according to the spirit
so the bible tells us that there's no
condemnation to
those who are in christ so even if you
feel condemned even if you feel guilty
for what you've done in the past
the good news is that jesus is willing
not only willing
he wants to forgive you he wants to set
you free so that you don't walk around
feeling a burden of guilt and shame and
condemnation
he says there's no condemnation to you
when you give your life to jesus
now now correct me if i'm wrong but do
they historically believe that this
woman that was caught in adultery
is that um mary magdalene
some do and other others disagree i
think it was
yeah yeah because i mean it just makes
sense like here look at look at the look
at the
what happens after that i mean she
becomes a
just close follower of christ after that
experience i mean they i
i think the bible talks about seven
demons were cast out of her
and so you know you think of the freedom
that
um she found in christ and i think
that's exactly like what you're saying
right christ can offer you that freedom
and you can be free
totally totally absolutely so to
give a perspective on that
some people believe that those seven
demons that are being cast out is
actually
seven different encounters where she
went back to the same activity over and
over again
and so jesus had to free her from that
multiple times
before she was finally set free
and i think the lesson in that is you
can come to christ
he will cleanse you he will forgive you
you may fall again
but don't stay down get back up and let
him you know continue the process
i am very glad that you brought that up
i i just want to kind of pause on that
thought for a second
and let people because i i want you guys
to know
that if you're caught in a cycle of
pornography
or sexual relationships outside of
marriage or whatever
i mean it is it is the devil who wants
to just beat you
up in that space and when you feel more
depressed and more just i can't believe
i did that again i fell again and it
keeps that
cycle and that dysfunction going whereas
god is offering us
freedom and sometimes it does take us
keep coming to christ keep literally
on our hands and knees like lord take
this from me take this from me i mean
you know for whatever reason this is a
powerful powerful thing that god
built into humanity to keep us together
so we think that you know we can easily
get out of this sometimes and god
designed it to be a sticky glue
situation and sometimes we get stuck in
that situation
also to bear in mind like not to
fantasize it that we go to god
and what he does he takes away our shame
he takes away the penalty of that sin
which is death and we are become new
creatures
but one thing god doesn't do he doesn't
take away the consequences of what we
did
and that is going to take work to get
through um all the traumas that we put
ourselves through whether it's
counseling or you know
the actions that we have to take he's
working side by side with us but this
isn't something that you pray and then
you're everything is brand new that's
right he's healing the wound but there's
still scars
exactly that's why the illustration of
food is so powerful because
you know a lot of people are looking for
the magical pill to lose that weight
but you know what it took you sometimes
months to put that weight
on and it's going to take you an
incredible amount of work to take it off
sometimes it's twice as much work
to take it off but you know god in
whatever cases sometimes he
immediately removes our desires in in
one swoop
and sometimes he works with us through
that process
the comment you made concerning the
woman caught in adultery
and how it may be mary magdalene the
same woman who
was released from demons seven times and
it may be seven
separate times and it got me thinking
how patient
god is with us but really why he's
patient with us
and i'm wondering if it's because he's
waiting for us to
make the change for the correct reason
when you think of all the different
times mary who we think is the saint
mary was delivered
she's brought in front of jesus caught
in an adultery
she's trying to escape shame or when she
like in all these different scenarios
like she's escaping something i wonder
if
at that seventh time she was finally
doing it for herself and she was ready
to like
break free and however long it took like
god is just patiently working with us
until we finally get it that i need to
do this for myself for the betterment of
not just myself but those around
me and for my connection with jesus
christ
can you imagine if there was a
punishment that was attached to that
woman
who was caught in the act of adultery
right so all of a sudden jesus was like
look
okay well now you're gonna be you know
like
punished for this amount of time and
stuff like this until you kind of give
it up right
would that have the same effect rather
than jesus was literally like
look you you have every right to be
punished like what these guys are saying
i mean
this this is the same being who wrote
the ten commandments from mount sinai
is the same being who who actually
instilled that
levitical law in into moses that yes if
you were caught in adultery you should
be stoned
and here he is on this side of the fence
the act of forgiveness
and what that actually did to her to
long-term
thing and i think i think that's what
the way god works with us is it's like
that act of forgiveness that he's
forgiving us
we trample on that we trample on that
but but finally i think he brings us to
this point where it's just like man he
just loves me
yeah like why am i still doing this
in the world he's doing that to us and
we should be doing it to other people
it's like lying here sexual sin here no
people go through these things and we
should have a forgiving heart and spirit
towards them as well yeah first
corinthians 13 11 says when i was a
child i spake as a child i understood as
a child i thought as a child when
but when i became a man i put away
childish things children babies
especially they live purely by feeling
when they're hungry what do they do they
cry when they
go to the bathroom they cry they live by
their feelings
and they want instant gratification
immediate gratification
but paul says that when we become adults
we're to learn to put away
childish ways instead of constantly
seeking for my own happiness we're
to even look for the happiness of others
and it's interesting that we become
more happy ourselves when we actually
seek to make other people happy
and lamentations 3 51 is an interesting
verse it's not about pornography
but the wise man said my eye affects
my heart now in the
hebrew mindset in the biblical mindset
the heart and the mind were synonymous
and you think oh that's kind of ancient
strange way of thinking
we use the same terminology today we say
i have something on my
heart and we don't mean literally on our
hearts it's the
mental and the emotional connection i'm
thinking about something
that means a lot to me i have an eye
it's on my heart we even say
i knew it i knew that verse by heart
and we so we use this terminology today
nothing has really changed when it comes
to that
but what we look at affects our mind and
our emotion it actually
emotions it actually changes us so i
want to look at some of the
research on this what about pornography
does it affect our heart meaning the
brain
pornography and memory research and
published in 2012 revealed that
pornography consumption has a negative
impact on working memory
now that's interesting because i was
reading um
an article by i think it's psychology
today if i remember correctly
and they say talking about pornography
is pornography okay and the
psychologists say absolutely their
pornography is totally fine there's
nothing wrong with it
and i think have they not looked at the
science
you know how could you make such a
statement and i'm not trying to put them
down i hope the best for
all those who are there but there's so
much research and we'll look at in a
moment we've just looked at one thing
but it is impactful they said it's only
bad if you think it's bad
but this research shows no it actually
has an impact on the memory
i'm sure most of like some of those
people were totally cool with
pornography but it still has a negative
impact on the brain
i i have a friend whose mother's a
psychologist and actually got into
um recently this summer a conversation
about this and for some reason we got on
the topic of pornography
and she was arguing that no this is a
prescription to
people in relationships to embed their
relationships
wow yeah yeah this is a common thing
that they actually use
in common psychology if people come to
them with marital issues
they will actually prescribe the use of
pornography i'll show you the research
on
porn in marriage and what it does and i
think if you actually go to anybody and
you say
when you're having sex you know are you
thinking of somebody else i don't think
anybody is ever going to say
i'm so glad you weren't thinking of me
you were thinking of someone else
who says that you know what i mean like
do you think it's like
wine how they're all these studies of
the negative effects of wine but then
they find this one little bit that
oh it has vitamins in there because of
the grapes so they harp on that like
yeah drink wine because you get these
vitamins instead of drinking
or eating grapes um and they disregard
all these bad effects do you think
that's well
for sure that is totally because it's
it's not like anything is a hundred
percent
bad yes wine has antioxidants that are
wonderful for you
but it also is bad for your brain it's
that it increases in
moderate use cancer rates and so so
there are benefits to it
see in the standard just to take a step
back the standard medical science
looks at health differently than a
biblical picture the bible wants to give
us
things that are beneficial without
negative side effects but the standard
medical system says
this pill may cause you know cancer in a
small amount of people
but it gets rid of headaches and so it's
worth it you know
and so so if you if you have that world
view you can see that okay
yes this may be bad for your brain but
when you have sex
it is good exercise you know and so i
mean they don't say that but
you understand that that you're you're
looking at it you're looking at benefits
and the side effects and it's the yin
and the yang they mix together and they
all come together and you just accept it
but
biblical the biblical perspective is god
wants wholeness
he's not wanting fragmentation and
brokenness so let's go forward on this
pornography and verbal memory research
on young people reveals that pornography
negatively impacts verbal memory of
males
and females so we know that it's
negative because we're going to look at
some research and
because of all the other research people
forget this study and the reason i say
it is this
most the studies are on men and or young
men and or men in general
and their effect on pornography and
they're not on women and so then women
always come and they ask
uh what's it do to a woman's brain you
know i mean
just because uh most research is done on
men doesn't mean it doesn't do these
things to a woman's brain
yes but but in this one we know that it
does negatively affect
the memory uh the verbal memory of
females also so we know it has a
negative impact on female brains so
why does it negatively impact the memory
i don't know i'm sure yeah
yeah i mean yeah there is just some yeah
i don't know what it is so
but jama journal of the american medical
association one of the most prestigious
medical journals in the united states
maybe the most uh so in jama psychiatry
they report on a study on brain scans of
men 21 to 45 years old
who were consumers of porn but not porn
addicts
they discovered that the brains of those
who had more of what they call phs which
are porn hours per week
were associated with lower gray matter
volume in the right caudate now let me
explain
the outermost region of the brain like
if you were to cut a skull open
and look inside what you would see is
the gray matter the outer portion of the
brain
is your highest reasoning centers of the
human brains the outer portions the gray
matter
and so what they've actually found is
that they actually have potentially
shrinkage
in those who are consuming porn not as
porn addicts
just casual porn users and it goes on to
say this
smaller gray matter was found in those
who consume
more pornography independent of if they
were internet addicted and the reason it
says that is because
we know that people who are internet
addicted that that also can shrink
the portions of the brain also the gray
matter and
so they said well regardless of
somebody's internet addicted so it's not
their internet addiction that
necessarily shrunk their brain
but even if they're not internet
addicted and they're just casual users
of porn it actually
shrinks the highest reasoning centers of
the brain
wow that that's interesting because if
you're addicted to looking at
cars you know what i mean like and you
want to look at those cars
all the time it's not negatively
impacting
the physiology of your brain in the way
that
something like this is and that just
goes for everybody that's like well
whatever it's just
you know i'm just watching something on
tv it's not affecting me you know i mean
here's proof in the pudding that that
does affect if you watch something
you're simply just putting your eyeballs
on it and it can have an effect on you
that's good like when when they say
casually watching porn does that also
include tv shows where the porn
flashes on the screen for like 10
seconds that's a good question
i don't know okay i don't know but but
probably to some degree
yes because some of the same emotions i
remember to be totally honest with you
just as a kid i was watching a movie
with my parents
and you know it there was no pornography
in it but it was just a
scantily clad woman and i remember
having the emotions that
sexual you know drive of a child i mean
literally just being a child
first time ever having that experience
of because you know when you're a little
kid unless you're
sexually abused you don't think sexual
thoughts unless they're kind of
places you learn about them you know
it's something that like as a little kid
you don't have those hormones raging
unless it
was done to you and i remember that
first experience
and so i would imagine that to some
degree it does because i had the same
emotions
that you would have had looking at
pornography but it was a pretty
tame movie that's something that
somebody most people would watch and
think like oh i wouldn't think that
would do that to you
but as a little kid who you know you
haven't seen those things it it affects
you and so
there's more than just the sight of it
too it's like you know if your parents
cover your eyes like this like i can
still hear
yeah that doesn't work does it so in
internet addicts they they know that you
have
10 to 20 percent deficiency
in speech memory motor control
like all these important areas of your
brain
and so you think about that like i have
a hard enough time as it is and do i
want 10 to 20
reduction in those areas and
it just goes to show the goodness and
the grace of god that we're even able to
reach
anybody with truth anymore because think
about it we're all
could probably classify as internet
addicts think about the amount of time
that you spend online
because of the devices that we have on
our person all the time
or you know even for our work
so yeah i mean this just makes it takes
it to the next level
totally so pornography and
loneliness actually before i even speak
on this
so we've seen that casual sex multiple
partners makes you more likely to have
suicidal thoughts
if evolution as it's standardly taught
that we're just animals and our whole
purpose
according to evolution is just to spread
our dna you have no other purpose you
are
that is 100 what you were made for
according to evolution
so sex is the highest aspect
of fulfilling your evolutionary
you know cycle except having the baby
come out but like that's what brings the
baby right
and so you would think casual sex
sex was as many people as possible would
make you the happiest
when that makes sense i mean if
evolution if standard evolutionary
theory were true
the happiest people would be like these
you know basketball players that have
slept with like 10 000 women
right but that's not what we see and so
what we actually see is once again
all god's commandments are for our good
good point he's not trying to keep us
from something
he's trying to bring us to something
better than we would ever have believing
in
false theories good point so um
back to pornography and loneliness
research has shown a predictive
correlation
showing with more time spent using
pornography predicting
statistically significant increases in
loneliness
and i'm sure the loneliness drives you
to more pornography
and it's just this like constant vicious
cycle yeah
yeah and i think that's partly what it
is is this
if you're selfish do you think you're
going to be
more lonely or less lonely yeah because
you're thinking of
self but if you're an other centered
individual you're thinking like hey man
how's your day going and you're like uh
you know scottie tells me yeah i'm
having kind of a rough day and and
and i begin to think about him and i
think hey man um
you know let's talk okay and so if i
begin to think more about him it's
interesting that thinking of others
actually makes us happier people but if
i'm constantly thinking like what can i
get out of scotty
like oh scotty's not doing good all
right bro hope you do better man hey man
how's it going you know
and if i'm constantly thinking about
self i'm not going to be happier and
pornography is a
it is a exercise in selfishness because
once again like you stated
i see that woman there and i don't think
care like oh she was probably sexually
abused as a little girl or maybe she
wasn't but she's forced into this and
she got with the wrong dude and
and now she's forced to go on camera for
my pure
selfish orgasm that's it you know that's
all that matters and
we don't like to think of it that way
but that's and so we see that people
become more
and think of that only the way that we
are kind of
training people as a society if
if you as a child are growing up in the
school system or just society in general
and
and it's like well you do you really
didn't
fail you know we're just gonna pass you
on or
everybody got first place or whatever
you're kind of setting everybody up for
this
like rejection is the most horrible
thing
that's ever happened on the face of the
planet and so now you can't deal
right you can't handle any kind of
rejection so what do you do
comes time you're like a teenager early
20s you're going to go out there you're
going to see
i guess to use the worldly term play the
field right see let's see what's going
on
and there's pornography you're like well
i could get rejected
or i could just go someplace where i
always know i have acceptance
right and so then it's kind of like just
continues to feed
that cycle but you also think of the
programming that's happening too
i have two nieces one just turned 18 and
the other ones are 15 14
and so i've actually asked my nieces
like they go to a public school system
and they say that before class starts
every kid has a phone
and they sit around and they literally
show each other the latest and craziest
porn and
they literally look at the porn at as
like
they try to one-up each other but look
how crazy this is and it's just like
this insane so their education
of what is even going on in the bedroom
is literally coming from that so it is
it is zero education on what can i do
for the other
person it is literally like like look at
what they made her do or look at what
she
did or whatever like this and then when
they get into a real relationship that
is a
unrealistic picture of actually what
even happens
and they're disappointed and on both
sides of the fence i'm sure they're
completely disappointed
that's another good plug for childhood
2.0 link in the description i mean they
talk about that
same stuff yep wow wow
you know jeremiah 29 as we talked about
it
tells us that god's plans for us include
wholeness
he wants us to be whole and whole
is it's a word like it's so deep
sounding meaning you know it
it means not just having temporary
pleasure like yeah okay you have sex
with somebody
there's a temporary pleasure in the act
of it but then there's that once again
corresponding brokenness
fragmentation afterward but whole would
be
being able to have sex and actually have
fulfillment and i think people think
because they see like married people who
are happy and i don't mean all marriages
are happy that's totally not the case
but there are
really happy marriages out there and the
people who stay married with one person
actually statistically are the happiest
people and
so they think oh there must be a way to
do it to make it right and if i just
found the right person i just keep
having sex with this one this one this
one you got to have sex with them to
know if it's going to be good right
well that's not what the research
actually shows the people who have the
greatest sex life
aren't those who did that right they
aren't the people who really learn to
have sex with
many different people they're they're
you know people who actually stuck with
one person but
this is something called prolactin a
hormone that is in our body prolactin is
a hormone that causes
satiety or fulfillment after a sexual
experience
it has other functions in the body as
well research reported in the journal
biological psychology
reveals that after intercourse the
levels of prolactin are 400 percent
higher
than after masturbation the researchers
conclude that intercourse is evidently
more
satisfying physiologically than
masturbation
and so once again masturbation doesn't
have the fulfillment that sex does so
you might be thinking
okay i shouldn't just mess around then i
should go actually just have sex with
people and it'll be more fulfilling but
we've already found the answer to that
the answer to that is
that every time you have casual sex with
somebody raises your chances of having
suicidal thoughts by 18
so no when you put the studies together
we get a whole picture
is that when sex is done in the right
context
it actually does bring fulfillment
satiety uh you know this experience of
wow well that was nice and not the next
morning
feeling guilty right or not polar
opposite emotions from the same act
but ones with your your
partner for life that you've made a
commitment with a vow to god that you'd
stay with that one forever
that's that's pretty awesome that is
such a testament to how intricate god
created our system
the fact that our system recognizes the
difference between that
and is like nope i'm not satisfied yeah
that's not
that's not the right way right i'm not
gonna release that chemical you know
what i mean like that's amazing to me
that god actually has built this this
this thing that
and then he's given us the information
on this side that's what i think is so
beautiful
is he's saying listen if you just listen
to me if you just listen to me
you will be more satisfied i promise you
all my commandments are for your good
it's like if we would just if we would
just turn from the lie that no no god's
trying to keep me from something
no god's trying to bring me to the
greatest happiness i could possibly
have first corinthians 13 5 says that
love does not behave itself improperly
and seeks not her own meaning once again
this goes back to the idea that
uh love is not selfish
love does not think about itself love
seeks
the good of others that true love so uh
if somebody's
trying to get you to have sex with them
before marriage that's not love
and you think oh they really do love me
well if they really did love you
they would want to seek not their own
just sexual pleasure
they would want to seek the good of the
person
that is you yeah and if they really love
you why why not put a ring on it or
whatever you know
they really love you then stay with me
forever you know and then we can do that
yeah i think long term like when i'm
looking for a life partner i'm
also looking for a good father figure
and if he can't control himself how can
i expect him to teach
our kids self-control great point great
point and
and if he's doing that with you will he
you know be more prone to be tempted to
do that with somebody else while you're
married you know that
that gives you the idea so t speaking to
pornography and marriage
which we had mentioned earlier maybe
maybe it'll spice up your
uh marriage life and your sex life in
marriage and maybe you would just get
better and
you could just do that right um well
let's look at the research
research on over 20 000 married people
this is not a small study revealed that
people who watch
pornography in the last year were more
likely to get divorced
more likely to cheat on their spouse and
less likely
to have a happy marriage isn't that
fascinating
and going back all god's commandments
are for our good
because you could say well sex and
pornography are two
very different things like sex is like
actually the connection
with a human body and pornography is
just you know looking at a body and
then imagining the act but you remember
that jesus said in matthew 5
28 but i say unto you that whosoever
looks on a woman to lust after her
has committed adultery with her already
in his
heart that's a good point it's like
literally bringing
a adultery situation even in the
covenantal marriage bed
where really you're kind of both
committing adultery
so what's the next easiest logical step
i mean it's like you've already
committed it over here relationship
yeah open relationship yeah and all that
yeah
yep and even if you don't aren't open to
that
you might have it accidentally you know
the other one here's another thing too
like
it's it's like playing russian roulette
right if you knew this statistic was
real and you really sat down and you
really believed it
would you even want to open up the
possibility yeah maybe you won't cheat
but statistically proven and 20 000
married couples right here
one of you is more likely to actually
walk away and it's like to enter that
into the marriage situation
it's like the same thing i'll go bring
it back to the heroin thing if you knew
you don't know when you before you try
heroin you don't know if you're one of
those statistical people that cannot
stop that thing
and you see where that in conclusion
goes it goes to death
and so it's like if you don't know what
you don't
is that going to open up your marriage
to this tragic situation
yeah well i don't understand why it's
such a concern no maybe i'm thinking
about this way too simply so you guys
can help me out sure but why is it a
concern that
um long term it'll be an issue in a
marriage um to be having sex with the
same person they're
looking for ways to spice it up and all
these things adding porn adding toys all
of that
and i'm thinking okay what do i like i
love avocados
like as is i could take avocado eat it
just as it and that's a meal for me i'm
happy i feel satisfied
and i can do the same thing tomorrow
it's been 23 years
i haven't stopped liking avocados so if
i'm with someone
i don't like if i love them and my full
attention is on them
why where's that coming from that i
would need to
add all these different things to keep
my interest in them maybe they didn't
love them in the first place you know
they're just having uh infatuation
sometimes that may be the case and other
times they may have actually really
cared but now
they've stepped over the edge on
starting looking at things and
this yeah now they're 40 50 years old
and here's a beautiful
18 20 year old and so like you know so
maybe they did originally love and now
it's just going down
a sad route yeah i think it's exposure
you love avocados but then you get
exposed to wow there's this
big avocado they have in africa or
whatever and you're like well this
give me that one well i
i don't know just just looking at from
my own marriage
situation like i i sometimes am sitting
back
and and staring at my wife and going man
it's crazy like i feel like
like i love her more and more and as
more time goes on
it's like all of the experiences that
we've had
i mean just the little tiny things that
my wife does it's like she does these
like
ridiculous little things like we have
this little chalkboard on our board and
sometimes she'll write a
bible verse on there or whatever like
that i mean something as ridiculously
simple as that i never even see her do
it
and i was looking at the chalkboard this
morning and i was just like
i love my wife like she just wrote you
know may god bless us on our trip and
this and that on there or something like
as we just go back from her trip
and so it's like those little tiny
things that i think have opened me up to
more and more of a of a love for my wife
over time
and it's like all those experiences
together has has
like expanded that love back to your
question
so i you know grew up eating
all kinds of food you know my favorite
food was pork growing up and
and then i switched to a plant-based
diet and i learned to like
plants you know like like fruits and
vegetables and
and plant-based food and i got to the
point where i had i had shared with you
guys in the past that i had depression
and then i went on a very simple
diet i had gut issues and then went on a
a very simple diet for like two weeks
which is extreme i wouldn't suggest most
people do it but i just was eating fruit
um for a couple weeks some people just
can't do it but i felt great
and my depression began to go away but
after that
and then i began to be happier than i
had ever been in my life then
i began to love fruit i would like love
it like a banana
like wow and like i've never felt that
way about a banana right
or or literally like eating some dates i
was like this is like
heavenly this is incredible but i can
tell you this
i also but but i never stuff myself with
bananas till i'm like
but i remember uh and this isn't even
like a real
terrible junk food but there's something
in it that troubles you
and it's so tomato basil wheat fins
yeah that sounds pretty innocuous like
come on that's not like bad bad food and
it's not bad bad food
but it has one thing in it that is msg
and monosodium glutamate is
a flavor enhancer that you put it in any
food and that food
it like blows up in your brain it
literally they say is like
in the brain is an experience of like
wow like whatever you put it in it makes
it better and
actually in world war ii the as the
americans took over
japanese rations they ate their rations
and they're like
their food is better than us why the
japanese have better food than the
americans do and it was msg you put msg
and everything tastes better
and so getting off the subject if i if i
open a box of tomato basil
wheat thins it's hard for me not to eat
an entire box
literally but so i don't even need them
anymore because like i don't want msg to
be honest with you i don't need that
but and i'm not judging anybody that
yeah but you get the idea
so my point is that certain things can
have an
excitement level but then at the end of
an entire box i don't go
ah now i'm fulfilled you know like now i
feel better with my life no you're like
i ate a whole stinking box of tomato
basil wheatons
and so the same thing can happen like
with immorality
with immorality brings an excitement
that like sexual you know watching
people do things or
or whatever there's an excitement there
that is not
fulfilling but it is exciting and and
the wheat thins
with msg are exciting but not fulfilling
and so then you crave more of that
because our brains are kind of designed
to do that but
when i eat the foods that are healthy i
actually love them
and they are fulfilling and yes they
don't have that crazy exploding in your
brain feeling
but they are like wow that feels so good
and then i feel good that day
and then later that day same thing with
marriage
one more follow-up question do you think
the issue is the obsession over it
so going into marriage understanding
that sex is important
but you know obsessing over it making
sure it's okay or is my partner
fulfilled should we spice it up you
think that's what's causing the issue
that
later down the road unfulfillment would
grow
but if you communicate you don't have
that problem
right i mean if you're talking about it
hey are you all good you know okay you
know
i i don't think in and of itself
that someone gets bored in a marriage i
think once again it's what are they
watching
you're watching it may not even be just
pornography it could be porn
but it also could just be watching
movies with a bunch of hot people of
this sex that you're attracted to
we've actually heard people reading
romance novels exactly that actually
will tweak with their with their idea of
romance
and even just the just the steamy way
that it's written about they don't have
to be watching anything
it puts these wrong thoughts in their
mind and then they're constantly
comparing their own relationship to that
well i don't feel steamy like that women
a lot of people go into marriage
younger and and they have this
hollywoodized version which is the
you know the 5 to 15 minute scene of
that's what marriage is like and
everybody lived happily ever after
there's no day to day right there's the
washing the dishes is gone and taking
out the trash is
gone the cleaning up after the dog or
the cat is gone
the morning breath yeah the morning
breath the
the disheveled hair the sharks and the
kids have
worn you out completely that's all gone
all you get is the snapshot
you go into the marriage and it's like
wait a minute
it's not like sex every night like what
like what's going on here you know and
or or several times a day like
that's what was in the movie or in the
tv show and
and so people because of what they're
watching like he's saying
they have an unrealistic idea of what
marriage is about
marriage is a lifelong commitment and
it's based on a
principle called love not a feeling
called love
right and that principle called love
sees it through the end it serves the
other person
it takes out the trash and and
does the dishes and helps where
help needs to be right it does all those
little things and that's what helps make
up the marriage
the sexual activity is is only one part
a very small part of that small a small
it's an important part
but it's a small part if you think about
the amount of time that's spent
in that versus the whole rest of the day
and the life
and all of that so if you go into a
marriage thinking you know like
this is what it's all about then after
that plays out
you're going to be like well wait a
minute i thought it was supposed to be
different
24 hours and then you start looking
around like he's saying
i actually think that's a beautiful
illustration for how um
how our relationship with god is i mean
if you really look at the bible there is
some messy details
in the bible there is some unkept hair
some people worn out
god did get upset in certain situations
and some people look at the bible and
are just like you know like have this
sort of idealistic view of it
but when you read and you spend time
with that it's like you fall in love
with that person
and you see their love through that
experience and i think the same thing is
with your wife
when you have these um day-to-day
activities the way she cares for the
kids the way all these
these things play out the way that that
uh you know
the unglamorous parts are you then begin
to fall in love
with that person and and then that's
what brings about the satisfaction
is when you're looking at that person
going just wow like you know
it's amazing what she does for me and my
family and then all of a sudden you feel
drawn to them that was actually a
perfect segue
on oh don't you have sex every single
day i mean like i know before marriage
people think oh just like all the time
right
well then you find out life's a little
different than you might have imagined
girls to break this to you but uh
so they've actually done research on
that too increasing sexual frequency
and levels of happiness now obviously we
would imagine more sex
more happiness right well what does the
research show research out of carnegie
mellon
university put couples into two groups
they had one group
double the frequency of intercourse
whatever amount they did before so like
okay you did it twice a week
double it four times you did it once a
week double it two times whatever it is
so they had one group double the
frequency of intercourse while the other
group would continue at the same rates
as
previously and it turned out that those
who doubled their frequency
lowered their mood and happiness levels
oh wow
which is totally unexpected right
interesting
i would not have expected that but
that's what that's what research
shows now we do know some research on
they actually took monkeys
and they i don't know if they injected
or somehow they put
hormones into the female monkeys so that
they wanted to have sex all the time
well you'd think that would be great for
the male monkeys right it actually
like they would become like trouble like
it would it would actually
so i don't know and so
and so and this this is interesting too
though like that's
i made it sound funny like that but then
they
actually doing it too much made them
less interested in their partner
yeah and more interested in another
partner
that's interesting yeah so so the point
is
so how much should you do it i don't
know
you know but don't overdo it either
because uh
sex is meant to be a blessing none of
this is trying to say sex is not a
blessing it is meant to be in the right
context of great blessing
so the point is too much of a good thing
there is something the bible talks about
that's temperance
that you avoid things that are bad and
you moderately do
the good things and then you'll actually
be the most happy but
let's talk about just a couple points
on victory over sexual
issues whether it's porn whether it's uh
just
overconsumption of sex in general but
hebrews 13 verse 4 says marriage is
honorable
in all and the bed undefiled meaning the
bible doesn't look as
sex as a defiling thing in
a marriage there's nothing defiling
about it a friend of mine
he said uh uh you know he was you know
in the world you know sleeping with
prostitutes and doing things he was a
drug dealer and
and then he later on gave his life to
jesus and
the guy's powerful today he's one of my
favorite speakers in the world
and he's like a philosopher he's just a
genius but um
he said hope he doesn't hear this but
then he he said to us that
when he got married when he would have
sex with his wife at first he'd be like
almost felt guilty and he's like oh i
don't have to feel guilty
you know i was like because he was just
used to sex as being an evil thing and
then it's like oh no i actually get to
feel
fulfillment in it and so in saying that
but he did not just like give his life
to jesus and then like
get with another girl and go get married
he waited like
i want to say like 10 years and i don't
mean you need to wait 10 years but he
waited
a long time before so he was really
kind of like dealing with those
consequences he was cleansing and
dealing with the consequences dealing
with the
the thoughts of these things the good
thing is is that time
begins to change us it heals it cleanses
our minds now we're not just
cleansed in and of itself the bible says
in
john chapter 15 and verse 3 it says now
you are
clean through the word which i have
spoken unto you
and so my friend also shared this he was
same guy
he you know like i said been with the
prostitutes dealing drugs he actually
had like you know he'd have five
thousand dollars in his pocket you know
he had the drugs in his car and he drove
into this bible seminar
it was like a tent meeting you know like
he was a drug dealer he sees this
tempting he's like
i should go check that out but he's on
his way to a drug deal
and so he's got to go deal the drugs
afterwards right so he goes to this
meeting
and he he sits down he listens to the
message and at the end of the message
the speaker was asking people to stand
up and give their life to jesus
wow and as he heard that he felt so
dirty right
because like all the things he had done
he felt so dirty
and the thought came to him he's like i
don't even think i could stand because
like i'm so
filthy how could i stand up and give my
life to jesus
but then the thought came to him
what if what if i stood up
and i could feel clean for just one
minute
for just one minute he thought
if i would feel clean for just one
minute it would be totally worth it
and so he stood up he gave his life to
jesus
and he's a minister today he's got a
wife and
beautiful children and and the point is
his story is a real beautiful story i
don't mean you need to take 10 years
between
your immoral lifestyle and you know
getting married
but i would challenge you whether it's
pornography
not you'd never go back to pornography
it's not it's not i mean
intentionally you know god can forgive
you if any man sin we have an advocate
with the father jesus christ
if you fall back into it jesus can
forgive
but he wants to give you ultimate
victory but when it comes to like sexual
relationships by god's grace
i would challenge you to let go and
begin that healing
process where you can you can get to the
point where you are
number one in christ we are born again
amen
we get to start over we don't have to
say well like
i because imagine saying for the rest of
your life
let's say you cease porn consumption and
then you say for the rest of your life i
am a porn addict
well you may be if you go back to it but
god just like
let's say you grew up lying all the time
if you stop lying
are you a liar for the rest of your life
and you were a liar right
you were a porn addict and jesus really
truly can cleanse you john 15 3
now you are clean now you are clean
through the word which i have spoken
unto you
yeah and so one thing i would challenge
you
one thing that began to change my life
gave me victory over addiction
i began to read the bible through i had
an atheist challenge me
someone who didn't believe in god and
i'm so glad he did i
believed in god but i wasn't following
god you know it was like
if you ask me are you a christian i
would have said yes but i was
as much of a christian as i was an
astronaut
and if you would have been like chad are
you an astronaut and if i would have
told you yes so you would have been like
do you are you in nasa did you fly you
know in space
and i was like no and then you're like
well how are you an astronaut i'm an
astronaut in my heart
that doesn't make any sense right and so
that being said uh if i'm only a
christian in my heart but not in my life
am i really a christian and i wasn't a
christian and so i had an atheist ask me
so you're a christian yes um tell me the
ten commandments
and i was like uh
i was like yeah i don't know and he's
like you're a christian you don't even
know the ten commandments and i was like
yeah and i realized like i look like a
fool but he didn't stop there like he
wasn't done with me
he's like so you're a christian i was
like yeah he's like do you believe in
the bible i said
yeah he said have you read it wow and i
was like
uh yeah no and he's like so
how do you believe a book you've never
even read wow and
you know you you christians come up with
these like
like sunday school answers or whatever
you know or church school answers where
they're like
uh yeah the answer is jesus yeah jesus
faith you know it's like by faith no the
bible says so then faith comes by
hearing and hearing by the
word the word of god so if you haven't
been to the word
it may be blind faith because you don't
even know what it really says
and so i selfishly that day decided i am
going to go home and i'm going to read
the bible through
so that nobody can ever ask me that
again pure selfishness right
and so then i began i would put chewing
tobacco in my mouth and i would begin
reading through
the bible day by day by day by day i was
chew tobacco
and and i didn't know that the bible
said that my body was the temple of god
and that i was not to destroy god's
temple and think about this
pornography destroys the temple not just
tobacco that's right
pornography shrinks the brain and where
is the one place
in the human body that we connect with
god
the brain specifically the higher
regions of the brain right i mean in our
gray matter which we know specifically
may be shrinking from
things like over consumption of media
and pornography
so thinking about this i began reading i
didn't know all this stuff but i began
reading through the bible
reading through and it was that process
of spending time in with jesus daily and
i don't want you to think it was like
i started reading and then bam you know
like i gave up alcohol and i gave up
cigarettes and i
stopped chewing tobacco and no it was a
process
it was a process and still a process for
that matter right
it's still time of growth and so i would
challenge you
spend time in the bible you may find
just like i did that when i began to
read the bible i didn't even like it
i'm gonna be totally honest with you but
the bible says in first peter 1 23 that
you are born again
by the word of god meaning as you spend
time we are cleansed by the word of god
it doesn't say you're going to like it
actually the exact opposite you know the
bible says
in romans that we by nature are at
enmity with the law
and god's law is not only the ten
commandments but it's the whole of god's
word right
by nature we're against the bible and so
as i read it i didn't even enjoy
to begin with wow but over time it began
to change my life i began to love it
and i got to the point where my life
began to change
i i learned that god wanted me to give
up the addictions not just myself it
wasn't just me that i was sick of them
but i was addicted to them i still
wanted them but i wanted to let go of
them
i realized that god actually wanted to
give me the victory
and one of the things is knowing that
god truly wants
you to have the victory because he wants
you to be
fulfilled he wants you to have peace in
your heart and
you can be cleansed through the word so
one simple thing is spend time with god
in prayer
and spend time in god's word daily
and we're going to talk more in the next
episode
about specific things we can do to
overcome
habits in general but specifically
pornography amen
man chad powerful powerful testimony
we hope you guys were seriously blessed
by this we know
look if you are struggling with this
topic you are not
alone i mean if we would all be honest
with every single
male now female probably on the face of
the planet
has literally come to battle this topic
and
literally christ can help you through
this you can be victorious
chad tell us where can we find more
material like this how do we get a hold
of your
tell them tell them what your website is
yeah yeah so our website with our
documentary films our seminars on
overcoming habits and addictions
is anchorpointfilms.com
anchorpointfilms.com all like one word
and we also have a youtube channel where
you can watch
video after video on a mixture of
science on health
mental health happiness and also
physical health when it comes to the
body
and that's that's our youtube channel is
health and homestead so if you just look
health in homestead you can look at our
videos on there visit our brothers at
school for profits dot tv
and watch from babylon to america which
has over 5 million views on youtube
alone
and follow it up with america 2 babylon
check the description below for links to
this and more thank you guys for
watching and
i'm excited to get into the next part of
this because
um i think we all need information on
how to get ourselves out of these these
things if we get
caught in that web what are we doing how
can we get out of it how can we become
free from that
so please you guys won't want to miss
the next episode but
as as always like this video subscribe
and uh thank you guys for watching we'll
see you guys next friday
[Music]
you